it's too I've been thinking lately about
the question of who is religious I mean
we all have this idea of what a
religious person looks like or what he
or she acts like but is it really that
simple sure religious is just a word
that we've invented and so however we
define that word also defines what a
religious person is but the problem is
that people define this word very
differently and thus there is a lot of
misunderstanding and confusion about
this when does a person become religious
like where's the line drawn is there a
scale and if so what does that scale
look like if you've seen my previous
video on religion you'll know that there
is no official definition for that word
and needless to say the same applies for
the word religious as well we don't like
to use that word academically at all
because of how problematic it can be let
me think about this we like to consider
Saudi Arabia a very religious country
right I mean it's a Muslim country the
laws of restrict the women are usually
veiled and so on but in Saudi Arabia
really a very religious country or does
sorry but just follow a more strict
interpretation of Islam I mean there's a
difference there see this is where the
problem often arrives here in the West
where we consider ourselves to be very
secularized we often associate more
religion with more strict right so the
more religious a person is the more
strict he is or the more religious a
person is the less open-minded he is to
put it in other words more religion
equals bad and less religion equals good
but isn't this just our Western
secularized view that religion is
somehow opposed to the ideals of modern
society that that religion is associated
with all the ideas and something that
represents a bygone world are we still
really feeling the effects of the
Enlightenment when religion and all its
expressions were considered to be in
opposition to everything we wanted to
achieve as a society I mean is it really
true that if you are more religious than
you are necessarily more strict or more
rigid let's take an example so let's say
there are two women and
both of these women are Christians so
they grew up in a Christian family they
live in a Christian country and so on
the first woman let's call her Linda she
lives a rather strict life she doesn't
go out much she doesn't drink any
alcohol she dresses very modestly and
she always wears a crucifix and all of
this because she thinks that's what's
appropriate for a Christian woman the
second woman and her name will be with
Sarah she doesn't do any of these things
she goes out she drinks alcohol she
dresses and acts like any other person
on the street but every night before she
goes to bed she prays for 15 minutes she
always goes to church on Sundays and
when she's feeling down she reads the
Bible for comfort now which of these two
women would you say is more religious
let's take another example two Muslim
guys one is this stereotypical Muslim
dude like he has this he wears the long
white Muslim garb he has a long beard he
doesn't think women should be able to
drive because Islam says so he thinks
music is forbidden because Islam says so
he's very keen to follow the Sharia and
he encourages others to do so as well
but he doesn't always pray five times a
day and he has never really read the
Quran and it's entirely now the other
guy he lives in Germany he dresses in
western clothing he is a feminist and
sometimes on weekends he plays at the
local clubs with his metal band but he
never misses a prayer and he does dhikr
one time a week and he's always thinking
about God now which of these two men
would you say is more religious or more
Muslim here we're kind of getting into
the territory of what religion actually
is we discussed this briefly in a
previous episode about religion and
explained that religion can mean very
different things to different people and
people have different ideas about what
the core of religion is so for example
if you think religiosity is mainly a
personal belief or faith then you adhere
to every Protestant Christian idea of
religion and religiosity well other
cultures or regions of the world may
sort of emphasize the more external
aspects like family or behavior or law
or politics or whatever to be
the core of religion and religiosity we
often hear about a kind of identity
crisis that appear in minority
communities as a result of this kind of
understanding so a Muslim woman for
example may often feel that she has to
hide her religiosity in order to fit
into society people have a tendency to
believe that you are more Muslim if you
wear a hijab for example and this
creates a kind of dichotomy between
Islam and Western culture where the
former is seen as being in opposition to
the latter the more a person goes
against the norms of Western society the
more Muslim they are in this case and
this isn't necessarily true at all but
this kind of dichotomy sort of often
leads to things like bigotry and
ultimately racism as well but this leads
me to another related subject like
anyone with good taste in music I really
love the Beatles it's a group of just
really great songwriters and one really
good drummer but it's no secret that
their lead guitarist George Harrison
throughout his life was very much
interested in into Hinduism there are
Beatles songs that like within you
without you that clearly express
philosophies related to Vedanta and
things like that the time will come when
you see we're all one and life flows on
within you and without you and so on
especially after the Beatles in his solo
material this could be seen is album
living in the material world is almost
exclusively made up of devotional songs
to the divine but there are lot of
different opinions about this not just
if people like or don't like this
direction he took but also what it means
and what it actually is that he's doing
well I personally wouldn't hesitate to
call George Harrison a very religious
person there are a lot of people who say
that he now is just philosophical he's
just spiritual but what's the difference
here really there seems to be this idea
in the West that Eastern religions like
Hinduism or Buddhism are often more
spiritualities than they are religions
than people practicing it are more
spiritual than religious one reason for
this could be that these religions like
Buddhism when they are imported to the
west and a Western market are often D
religion eyes that is main aspects of
those religions that we would consider
religious
I've been removed from them when they
are imported to the Western market so
the kind of Buddhism practiced by a
Swedish convert may be completely
different from one practiced by an
Indian or someone in China another fact
it could be that we here in the West so
strongly associate the word religion
with the judeo-christian Islamic
framework and so this becomes the
framework by which all other religions
are measured as well in their sort of
scale of religiosity or scale of how
much of a religion they are I mean yeah
George Harrison songs are very
philosophical but those philosophies are
usually directly linked to religious
teachings within Hinduism and so doesn't
that make them religious this apparent
dichotomy between religious and
spiritual is very interesting a lot of
people claim that religion is indeed
going away in the West
church attendance is getting lower and
so on but it's actually a lot more
complicated than this it is true that
people in Sweden for example have been
moving away from Christian dogmas in
their institutionalized forms but does
this necessarily make them less
religious in a book that came out three
years ago historian of religions David
2dl writes the following in terms of
faith and philosophy Swedes have gone
through a change away from
institutionalized Christianity and its
dogmas but they have not abandoned a
religious way of approaching existence
actually some research have shown that
things like belief in an afterlife have
actually increased and the number of
people who don't believe in a God or
supernatural power or force decreased
between the years 1981 and 1997 this is
all in Sweden by the way Sweden also
ranks second in all of Europe when it
comes to number of people believing in
some sort of spirit or life force and
that God is something that lives within
us rather than outside
in spite of commonly being considered
one of the most secularized countries in
the world this is perhaps best
exemplified when showed if you ask
someone if they are religious or what
they believe in especially in Sweden it
is very likely that you will get an
answer like wow I'm spiritual but not
religious or I believe in something but
maybe not the God of religions and so on
this is a very common answer but in
certain situations like a crisis
or a national tragedy or things like
this we can clearly see that people
start sort of falling back on their
traditional religious values and
practices in this case the Christian
tradition so it's a very complicated
situation let's say it seems that if we
define religious as specific adherence
to a institutionalized religion and its
theology then indeed it appears that
it's decreasing in a way but if we
define the word more broadly than it
certainly is not that simple people
clearly still believe in things that
appear irrational or sometimes
supernatural we can see this in for
example the emergence of the New Age
movements or they're in sort of renewed
interest in Eastern religions that
aren't considered religious in the same
way what do you think
what does religious actually mean who is
religious and is there a difference
between spiritual and religious leave a
comment and we can continue this
discussion there and I'll see you next
time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]